[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et heureux de vous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro du sky
échos le récit de la vie des acteurs
économiques du territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines
nous sommes chez air captifs basée à
trappes
sa spécialité la production de
structures gonflables dédiés aux
secteurs de la défense de l'aéronautique
du médical ou encore du loisir son
actualité
la relocalisation d'une partie de son
activité de la chine vers la france
c'est l'objet de ce treizième numéro du
sky et qu ils se réunissent chaque année
pour l'innovation en ile de france cette
année tech'innove rassemblera les
entreprises et des institutions en visio
conférence le jeudi 1er avril
immersion au sein de l'entreprise erp
captifs à frappe cette société fabrique
des structures gonflables et souhaitent
re localiser sa production en france
enfin focus sur le partenariat entre esp
sécurité et le lycée louis-blériot deux
trappes autour de l'alternance et de
l'accueil des stagiaires
elle a multiplié son chiffre d'affaires
par quatre en 2020 une performance
réalisée par éric actif sept entreprises
face à la crise sanitaire s'est adaptés
en développant des produits destinés à
la crise sanitaire et aux patients
qu'aux vide
[Musique]
cette société implantée à trappes compte
près de 30 collaborateurs elle réalise
en moyenne 1,2 million d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires son projet
relocaliser une partie de son activité
de la chine vers la france et pour en
parler nous sommes avec emmanuel fievet
bonjour autour des colas
[Musique]
vous êtes le cofondateur d re captifs
alors pourquoi avoir choisi de
relocaliser une partie de votre activité
en france alors effectivement on
souhaite relocaliser parce que tout
simplement on sort du mode start up et
notre société va sur sa quatrième année
et dans un premier temps on nous
n'avions pas tout ce dispositif toute
cette cuisine là qui fait des 2800
mètres carrés ça à peine un an ont
fabriqué en chine on chine tout
simplement
et aujourd'hui compte tenu des clients
que l'on en a dans la défense dans le
médical dans le spatial on a décidé de
relocaliser effectivement l'ensemble de
nos travaux pour être à la fois plus
disponibles plus présent avec nos
clients et pour qu'ils puissent voir
toute la fabrication et être plus
réactif a effectivement c'est un peu
plus cher
ya pas de doute pas tellement plus cher
mais on a cette volonté là c'est un show
un véritable choix stratégique a
totalement
le premier choix stratégiques on l'a vu
pendant la période de coheed c'est que
voyez bien quand il ya des problèmes on
n'a pas non produits et à la fin
derrière les produits il ya des clients
donc
ce qui s'est passé pendant la période
des cohabitent des clients ils ont
attendu leurs produits pendant six mois
donc ça c'est une expérience qu'on n'a
pas voulu renouveler et donc on a pris
ce virage et vous voyez cette pièce là
que vous avez autour de vous à peine un
mois et demi il y avait personne dedans
et donc on
on a décidé de prendre un par un les
produits d'art captifs et de 6 m voilà
est donc là ici vous avez premier
produit c'est un abri pour piscine et
qui est fabriqué en france
ce c'est un projet qui va être
accompagné en plus dans le cadre du plan
france relance du gouvernement alors
totalement
c'est un projet d'envergure puisque ici
nous avons l'ambition sur une plaine
année d'embaucher 39 personnes
donc c'est assez exceptionnel deux ans
en ces temps difficiles et c'est pour ça
qu'on a fait candidature à ce fameux
plan de relance pour leur
industrialisation côté en nautique
presque on a aussi beaucoup de produits
pour l'aviation des produits qui
permettent de faire des gains de
productivité et des gains de
compétitivité
[Musique]
et on a rejoint ludovic volet bonjour
bonjour
ici
vous êtes directeur produits et process
der katif alors est-ce que vous pouvez
m'expliquer en quoi consiste l'activité
ici l'activité en fait ici donc il ya un
an on faisait surtout du prototypage et
la plupart de nos produits étaient
fabriqués en chine
donc aujourd'hui on réintroduit
l'ensemble de la fabrication en france
ici à trappes et donc toute la
difficulté tout le tout l'enjeu est de
réintégrer bain tout le tout la
fabrication avec un process qui
permettent d'être productif et de
s'aligner par rapport à notre concurrent
qui est la chine c'est investir dans une
nouvelle machine qui va nous permettre
donc points stratégiques de l'entreprise
c'est à dire que toutes nos pièces qui
sont fabriqués ici sont numérisées et
découpé sur ses tables de découpe
donc il nous en faut une deuxième
aujourd'hui pour répondre à l'ensemble
de l'activité
donc les pièces qui ont été découpés sur
la table viennent ici sur les lignes
d'assemblage soudure principalement dont
convient souder des valves et souder les
boudins hermétique non l'objectif ici
c'est l'étanchéité les pièces qui sont
fabriqués ici donc on a toute la valeur
ajoutée
on peut répondre très rapidement au
prototypage à nos clients et également
sur le service après vente
si jamais il ya un problème en pleine
crise et enfin on va terminer avec la
partie un peu industrie 4.0 on l'a vu
déjà avec les découper au début et là
une machine aussi qui permet d'avoir une
automatisation de la production alors
une automatisation jeu j'aime bien dire
que c'est un peu notre couteau suisse
aujourd'hui
cette machine là on fait nous permet de
faire et de la petite série donc tout
est numérisé et on peut lancer une
production avec un opérateur
hélas comme vous le voyez également ça
nous permet de faire du prototypage
merci vidéo volée merci beaucoup
directeur du process et des produits
chez air captifs et on poursuit c'est
sky aequo avec un rendez vous à noter
dans vos agendas le 25 mars prochain
saint quentin en
ils organisent un nid job dating dédié à
l'alternance un job dating virtuel dans
lequel vous pourrez décrocher votre
futur contrat en parallèle une série de
webinaires est organisée pour vous
accompagner dans vos recherches
pour vous inscrire rendez vous sur le
site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran et en parlant d'alternance le
groupe esp sécurité collaborent depuis
plusieurs années avec la filière
sécurité du lycée louis-blériot de
trappes
objectif permettre aux élèves de cet
établissement de compléter leur
formation en entreprise à travers des
stages ou de l'alternance les détails
dans ce business day
[Musique]
je suis bemba yatera je suis le
président du groupe e sp société
spécialisée dans la sécurité privée
[Musique]
m'appelle de christelle bonhomme je suis
professeur au lycée louis blériot à
trappes
j'enseigne au sein de la filière des
métiers de la sécurité
[Musique]
le partenariat avec le lycée
louis-blériot consiste dans un premier
temps de nous apporter des des
alternants le partenariat avec le groupe
sp nous permet de nous adosser au
savoir-faire d'une entreprise de pouvoir
les accompagner dans dans les métiers de
la sécurité leur apporter notre
savoir-faire notre expertise nous avons
beaucoup de stagiaires à peu près une
vingtaine depuis le début de l'année
nous avons également deux apprentis sur
le bac pro métiers de la sécurité et une
apprentie sur les bts management
opérationnel de la sécurité pour nous ça
nous permet vraiment de pouvoir prendre
ces personnes on va dire les formes et
comme on a envie de 2,2 de les former et
derrière ça bat pouvoir les embaucher
[Musique]
l intérêt que trouve le lycée
louis-blériot partenariat avec la
société s p c'est de pouvoir mettre nos
élèves en situation réelle l'intérêt
dans ce partenariat c'est de pouvoir
prendre des jeunes et de pouvoir les
accompagner aider ces jeunes en fait à
trouver une voie nos élèves ont une
partie théorique et pratique au lycée
mais ils les ont besoin également
d'avoir le côté factuelle de
l'entreprise donc l'expérience que peut
apporter spa nos élèves
l'expérience ce terrain est bénéfique
[Musique]
l'idée c'est vraiment de pouvoir
renforcer notre partenariat avec avec le
lycée blériot développer nos contrats
d'apprentissage et nos stagiaires
également
[Musique]
rencontre avec thomas basso il est en
alternance chez tv 78 tant que webmaster
en parallèle il poursuit ses études à
lancy tech de guyancourt c'est la
séquence ma vie de salarié
je m'appelle thomas basso j'ai 19 ans je
suis alternant webmaster chez télé 78 et
je suis à l'école de hand sup à
guyancourt
[Musique]
parce que je fais au quotidien t 78
c'est de la maintenance au niveau du
site internet
égérie ficus tous les articles et toutes
les informations qu'on y rentrer
correspondant à l'actualité du jour je
m'occupe également de l'application
mobile donc sur android ios et également
sur amazon le sens que je donne à mon
métier c'est tout simplement qu'ils
aient tous les jours
enfin tous les jours il ya du nouveau on
se lève le matin on se dit qu'est ce
qu'il y aura de nouveau sur le site
internet ou question à nouveau à faire
aujourd'hui on a l'impression d'avoir
fait le tour et finalement non justement
c'est ça qui est palpitante
[Musique]
je suis embêté spéciaux slam donc
solutions logicielles applications et
métiers c'est tout simplement une
filière informatique de programmation et
j'apprends simplement à développer des
solutions logicielles pour les
entreprises
[Musique]
sma
j'ai choisi cette école et cette
formation tout simplement parce que
quand j'étais au lycée
je pratiquais beaucoup de la
programmation sur mon ordinateur
personnel
tout simplement pour créer des eaux au
départ des personnages en 3d en 2d
j'avais même créer mon propre jeu vidéo
en c# et chats au lieu de ré de faire ça
juste pour moi pourquoi pas essayer de
le faire pour une entreprise également
et avant de se quitter le rendez vous de
l'innovation en ile de france se tiendra
à distance cette année tech'innove c'est
le jeudi 1er avril
regardez
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette émission
enregistrée à trappes grk petit merci de
l'avoir suivi émission à revoir
henry clay sur notre site internet ou
sur l'application mobile à bientôt sur
tv 78
[Musique]